- Mike Rowley.
Uh, welcome to Ugly Pug Forge.
The reason why I named it
Ugly Pug Forge
is because I have two pugs.
They are just like me.
They're a little bit ugly,
but so ugly,
sometimes they're cute.
At least I hope.
That's what my wife says.
I started here--
right exactly here--
with a railroad track anvil
that I worked on
for about three years,
and it was not bad,
but it wasn't, you know, great.
So I sold my soul,
found a couple anvils,
and they're
definitely pricy now,
but these bad boys
are just like family to me now.
- My name's Cody Craig.
This is my shop here
in Bloomington, Indiana.
So come on in
and check it out.
When I was younger,
I threw a hammer
through a window,
and learned my lesson that way.
So now when I get frustrated,
you know, I just come over here
and give this a couple swings
and it--
it helps not be so frustrated.
Over here is my pride and joy.
I've got my big anvil
and my coal forge
and a couple propane forges.
This anvil, like I said,
it's my pride and joy.
It actually was
my grandfather's as well.
When he got it,
he actually had to restore it.
And now he passed away
24 years ago,
and it's definitely stood up
to the test of time.
- This is all my stack of steel
and all of this good stuff.
I've been collecting
for years now.
I use mostly recycled steel.
I'm a terrible golfer.
I still love golf.
I go as much as I can,
but I'm terrible.
This is probably, for me,
the best use of a golf ball
I can think of
just because the filing in that
tears up my hands,
but with that golf ball
on there,
then I can file all day
and not get torn up.
This is my shop.
This is where it all happens.
- Back kind of hiding
in the corner,
is a weird,
old-school buffing machine,
and this thing was actually
made in Indianapolis, Indiana.
Made by Kurt Vonnegut's family.
And that thing is a beast.
It was also my grandfathers,
and now it's here,
and it will be restored
and rewired,
and it will be returned to use
once again.
This has been my shop,
hope you enjoy it,
and thanks for coming out.